um so this is uh this is the top on
generalization bounds for neural network
based decoders
um
thank you to the organizers for having
me here and thank you for all of you for
coming uh this is Joint work
uh pretty much most of the work has been
done by the first author sudarsha nadiga
who's a PhD student
Xiao she finished her PhD now she's at
Apple and professors Bane and Tamal who
are at University of Arizona
so here's a quick outline of the talk
it's a little bit ambitious so I'll skip
depending on how much time uh Oliver
gives me uh so I'll start by talking
very quickly about uh where people are
using machine learning in communication
systems and Next Generation 6G and
Beyond uh then I'll maybe spend five to
ten minutes maximum on telling you what
has happened for machine learning for
channel coding a very quick overview
so that you are hopefully motivated and
with me by that point and then I'm gonna
talk about belief propagation neural
belief propagation and then present the
main result which is some theory for
neural belief propagation decoders okay
foreign
of using machine learning in area X Y or
Z as you can imagine it has also
percolated in the design of
communication systems and you can
imagine pretty much every single block
in the pipeline of a communication
system there has been efforts in the
last five to six years how to use
machine learning and more data and
design more data driven methods for
solving different blocks in a
communication pipeline starting from
designing better modulation schemes
doing better Channel estimation this is
one of the key components
um
designing beam farming you know using
Spectrum more efficiently and how to
allocate Spectrum how to use spatial
spatial frequency and temporal resources
um resource allocation if you think
about Edge networks you have large
number of devices which are which have
to be packed okay
and of course you know our most favorite
especially for this group Channel coding
designing better encoding and decoders
okay
so this talk is of course going to be
focused on the specific block which is
channel coding
uh more specifically within this context
I'm going to focus on design of better
decoders so I'm going to assume that I
have a message M so think of message M
as a sequence of K bits I'm going to
take my K bits map them to n Bits so
throw in some redundancy for error error
protection against errors then those uh
encoded bits are passed through a noisy
Channel then pass to a decoder which
tries to come up with a good estimate of
uh the original message all right
now as far as classical decoders go uh
you know think of these as man-made or
man slash human made Woman made decoders
uh we have a long list of classical
decoders sitting here including bit
flipping decoder bitter B bcjr belief
propagation turbo codes polar codes
successive cancellation list decoding
and the list goes on and on okay so of
course I'm gonna not gonna explain you
every single item in the list
but if you think about what's the
parallel situation as far as the machine
learning side goes
turns out the list is also growing
pretty quickly okay and more quickly
than this list grew over the last I
don't know 60 70 years right so there
are essentially you know AI aided
counterparts of the list on the left
um there are they are counterparts
sitting on the right so you have
reinforcement learning for bit flipping
and I'm just giving you a small you know
appetizer of what you will see if you
start searching for uh AI based decoders
uh there's something called the turbinet
there's a bcjr net there is neural
belief propagation neural successive
cancellation polar codes turbo Auto
encoder and so on so forth
anymore
there are there are papers on that too
as I said I will only focus on the
design of decoders for a fixed encoder
you can ask all sorts of questions you
know can we design them jointly
if I fix a decoder what's the best
encoder for this fixed decoder right so
there are many interesting flavors you
can ask
okay so as I said this is a partial list
so I don't want to yes so these talks I
like them because they're a bit
controversial
your comment is not completely Fair
because are there machine learning edit
decoders that are agnostic to what we've
done on the left
ah okay so I'll come to that good point
um so I'll come to that point in uh
maybe five minutes
so they are not necessarily agnostic in
which specific sense
so you know we needed to do the bcgr to
do bcdr network of course we need to
understand turbo to do anything so in a
way they're refining what we know so
there are two ways to go about defining
a good decoder either you ignore what is
known about a good decoding Corporation
you know what makes a good deal because
you ignore that knowledge and say let's
say I'm not a domain expert I haven't
take a course I haven't taken a course
in coding Theory so I'm gonna just show
noisy examples and trailer decoder and
learn good decoding rules that's one way
to go about it but then you have to do a
lot of work in terms of optimizing that
Network so a lot of noisy core words a
better way is to use domain knowledge as
you said and I think that's in some
sense that's what has happened
so yes
so I mean I'm just gonna I I'm sure as I
promise it was a great tutorial like icw
a few weeks back on something similar I
think they were long discussions about
that four hours after the tutorial
so you get this slide
so unfortunately you have three more
slides which are going to praise the
evil for machine learning decoders
so the first this slide is making the
point that you know because your scan
outperform classical counterparts so uh
so people have designed you know for a
given type of encoder let's say a
convolution and then turbo code people
have designed recurrent neural network
based decoders so which try to
achieve better performance or close to
Optimal Performance that you would get
by using let's say a bitter b or a BC
chair okay
uh same thing goes for let's say a bit
flipping decoder so people have used
reinforcement learning based with
fitting decoders and they give better or
close to comparable performance than
what we know by a man named
same thing goes for successive
cancellation decoder for Polar codes
now you may see these curves since you
can sort of ask this question uh well
you know they look similar or maybe tiny
bit better but it really depends what
you mean by tiny bit better you know if
you if you're at Qualcomm let's say uh
0.5 DB Improvement is a 50 000 days in
your salary right so it really depends
on what is better for who okay
um but one thing I should make a point I
should make is uh consistently what we
have seen in many papers is that you
achieve the best state-of-the-art
performance with reduced complexity I
think that's in some sense a good
achievement I would say
um other things people have looked at is
adapting or designing decoders which can
deal with channel uncertainties so I'm
giving an example of bcjr net where the
fully connected network is used to learn
the factor graph and then then they take
the decoder output by doing message
and same thing for the turbinet which
requires uh to compute the log
likelihood function requires CSI so in
some sense this method uh sort of
jointly computes an estimate of the CSI
and combines it with the steps of the
bitter blog
all right I know I'm going a little bit
fast because I want to come to my work
so if you don't understand everything
here no problem at all I will explain my
part very slowly
all right
um as I think one of the questions you
asked was join design of encoder and
decoder so there are a couple of papers
on that as well which is Turbo Auto
encoder which is uh which uses a
convolutional neural net architecture to
mimic the interleaved behavior of Turbo
and there is a recent book on chronica
operation based codes which is inspired
by polar and read mother quotes uh which
is also very interesting
so by the way I have some references at
the end so if you are interested in
exploring more and I think ITW tutorials
uh with both these things it will be a
good uh combination to uh pointers for
literature
all right so I think Matthew already
mentioned that typical ml architectures
do not necessarily completely use domain
knowledge
so there are several methods to
incorporate domain no domain knowledge
for Designing better decoders so first
of them is borrow the architecture let's
say if I am doing belief propagation as
I will talk about it in a minute uh it
has a certain type of
rules and a certain architecture certain
set of steps so you can maybe borrow the
architecture from the classical
algorithm and then do something data
driven to make that better right that's
one approach
there's another approach which people
have started to look at is learning from
the mistakes made by classical decoders
so if you design a classical decoder you
know that maybe it is failing on some
type of error patterns so you can
extract those error patterns and people
have done work on extracting when a
certain decoder fails
uh and then you can use those error
patterns and then show them in some
sense you think of these as adversarial
examples and then use them to stay in a
better decoder
all right so what I'm going to focus on
in this talk is uh not the most
sophisticated fancy ideas but just
focusing on the idea of let's say we
train a decoder by borrowing a classical
architecture what can we say what
theoretical guarantees can we give
sometimes so here's the setting we have
a block code a linear block code decide
by a parakeet Matrix
so you can also represent it by the
tanagraph basically number of variables
nodes number of check nodes represent
the number of parity checks or the
number of equations
and then I'm going to focus on belief
propagation decoder for the rest of the
talk
Bible propagation well again I don't
want to be contentious here and argue
this is one of the most commonly used
algorithms for decoding
um and the way it works is it computes
the channel log likelihood ratio values
and then does a sequence of operations
for a certain number of steps and comes
up with an estimate for the message bits
okay
how do these work
there are specific equations you can
write down if you know belief
propagation again I'm not going to spend
time on this part of the talk I'm hoping
that you know already what belief
propagation is so essentially it's
trying to take estimates of what we
believe is the right value of the of a
given bit at any given iteration and
based on that belief then we check
that's what the likelihood that given
this belief about the bits what's the
probability that a given check
constraint is satisfied or not and based
or not that we sort of go back and forth
between updating the belief for the bit
and checking whether the updated belief
is going to satisfy the checks or not
and then we run it for let's say t
iterations right so these are the
classical variable node and message
check node updates that they look like
and that final end this is what the
recorded output looks like
okay any questions so far
all right now this is what neural belief
propagation looks like which was
proposed I think five years ago
so what it does is it makes the
observation that doesn't this look very
much like a feed forward neural network
so what can we do to make it better
maybe we can do generalized or weighted
belief propagation where instead of
having fixed rules
we're going to do weighted updates so
wherever we see some incoming likelihood
llr coming in we're going to multiply it
with a weight
and same thing for this guy
and these weights are something that we
can try to learn
so we show noisy examples
and then we run the borrow the
architecture from belief propagation but
we sort of endow this network with
weights and the weights are learnable
right so this is what we call as
neural belief propagation right
so of course some parts of the things
people keep as fixed and again there are
you know reasons for doing some parts of
the corporation speak some parts of them
trainable again there is a lot of
heuristic uh things involved here that I
think over the years people have done
which which layers then they are made
trainable gives you the best bang for
the buck okay
all right
so
how do we how do we evaluate performance
of decoders we look at block error rate
or bit error rate so ber for the
remainder of the talk will stand for bit
error rate for me okay and
uh neural belief propagation has shown
to actually outperform belief
propagation especially in short to
medium block lists so not like 10 000
block plan codes but you know let's say
500 to 1000 block length codes it
actually performs much better than the
lead propagation
um and since the original papers
appeared there have been lot of
subsequent work on this so This neural
BP based decoding has actually gained
quite a lot of traction so people have
looked at uh offset uh Min sum quantized
versions of neural belief propagation
when the internal operations could be
quantized
people have also looked at knowledge
distillation and how to use uh uh you
know a larger neural BP to a smaller
neural BP to reduce complexity uh and so
on so forth
so what does this talk about this talk
is about understanding giving some some
theoretical bounds in terms of
generalization gap of neural belief
propagation reporters
so what do I mean by that
so let's say you take uh noisy code
words generated at a certain SNR okay
let's say you pass them you do a certain
modulation format pass them through a
channel and you generate your training
data set and you train your neural
belief propagation decoder and you get a
very nice bit error rate of 10 raised to
power minus 9. okay so this is what I'm
going to call as ber trading now I want
to understand that what's the what's the
expected bit error rate that I would
really see so this is just what I see on
my training data set on a small set of
noisy code words
uh so how does this difference look like
okay so of course people have studied
generalization Gap within the context of
statistical machine learning uh even Max
in the morning gave a very nice talk so
by the way I'm not an expert so if Max
is here please both me okay
um all right so the question that we
want to understand is can we bound this
difference and we want to understand
this difference how does this difference
behave as a function of the following
objects
the training data set size
training iterations these are standard
things which we which people test or
they try to bound the generalization Gap
and try to understand Behavior as a
function of these things
more interestingly we want to understand
how the Gap behaves as a function of the
decoder architecture itself
if the parity check Matrix is dense
versus sparse which one is easier to
learn either sparse parity check Matrix
easier to learn or a dense one easier to
learn
how does generalization Gap behave as a
function of the message length how does
it behave as a function of block length
as a function of code rate
or does it depend on the underlying SNR
so if you train a neural BP decoder or
at SNR of 5bb if I increase the SNR does
the training process become easier so
those are the questions you want to
answer of course you can imagine more
sophisticated questions in this list but
that's for another talk and another set
of papers right okay
yes question
is the most important one or it's one of
the most important ones yes
I
mean we are not going to tell you
anything new here the results the
dependence on the training data set side
training iterations I'm not going to
tell you anything
foreign
[Music]
so here is what my training data set
looks like I have some X1 X2 till XM
these are my noisy code words and
lambdas are my likelihood ratios you can
either view lambdas at the likelihood
Ratio or you can also view them as the
um
the
the channel output it doesn't matter you
can replace interchange be either one of
them doesn't matter
um and then now I'm gonna sort of bring
in the terminology from statistical
pack base bounce in machine learning so
now we are picking a neural belief
propagation decoder so we can view this
decoder as a function which takes the
channel likelihood ratio coming out from
the channel output and mapping them to
an estimate X
the whole the goal is to find a good
mapping f
which minimizes the uh the expected bit
error rate right so what is beta related
it's the Hamming distance between uh BF
Lambda and the actual X right
okay so in the ideal World our goal is
to find the F star that minimizes the
true risk which is the expected value of
the bit error rate when Lambda and X are
drawn from a certain distribution so
distribution means let's say you want to
find a good decoder which works at SNR
of 5 DB then you would want the best F
you can find for that channel condition
as an example and that specific code
right
but in practice of course we don't do
this we do empirical risk minimization
so we you know minimize find an F which
minimizes this guy
right so we can Define two things uh rbr
is the expected ber of a fixed F so
think of a fixed f as a given neural
decoder which has been trained and R hat
BR is the empirical BR of that fixed F
over the training data set okay
okay and then my my generalization Gap
is nothing but the difference of these
two now I want to bound this difference
for every F in that family of decoders
that I can pick from okay so these are
called uniform convergence pounds so I
want this difference to be as small as
possible for every F that I can pick
from that family of the quarters the
family of decoders is not governed by
the decoder architecture that I borrowed
from the classical world
okay
so we have of course we're going to make
some assumptions that the weights
matrices that we were dealing with will
assume that the weights are bounded
the input to the decoder that is the
likelihood ratios are also bounded
second one is a little bit not so
comforting but we will deal with this in
the second theorem so first let's deal
with this one first and then I'll come
to the next one
okay
all right so here's the standard result
uh we haven't done anything here this is
a classical result which says that if I
give you a function class F of T so
think of Ft as all neural decoders which
satisfy bounded weight property
then for every F in this family this x
this generation gap can be bounded as
some object here rmflt which is the radi
marker complexity of this function class
plus some term which behave like 1 by
square root f okay
what is this RMF LT this is essentially
how correlated is the uh is the BR
to random uh radi marker variables which
is basically plus minus one the
probability half right
so this is Rd marker complexity I know
many of you know it here but for those
who do not essentially it measures how
correlated a function is to random uh
uniform noise which is plus minus one
again I'm not being very precise here
but I hope it at least conveys something
so now the question is well we can just
directly lift this result we can do
there's nothing to be done so now the
question is can we bound this guy can be
bound to radio marker complexity and
understand its dependence on the same
set of things training iterations
decoder architecture and so on so forth
okay so that will be my next step
all right
so what do we do so first thing we do is
the first upper bound this guy in terms
of something called bitwise radio macro
complexity
so that's the first tiny proposition so
what it says is that
looking at this guy this guy we can
upper Bound by the average of something
what is this this is 1 by n n is the
block length remember the output of the
decoder is a n length object okay one
estimate for every bit
now I'm going to define a very similar
quantity but now for the jth bit so I'm
going to look at the radio marker
complexity of bjth output of that Vector
okay and then average this out okay so
the first frame is that we can show that
the radiometric complexity of the
original function class is less than the
average of the bitwise radi marker
complexity okay this makes a life a
little bit easier
okay so
let me clarify
this was defined as a correlation
between the loss
the loss was still a scalar but the loss
was dependent on uh essentially the
whole Vector all right Lambda was called
vector
but now I'm saying that I can upper
bound this guy in terms of average of
basically the same Supreme and
expectation sits outside but now I have
one by Sigma I and what sits here is the
the output of F and the average
okay so instead of taking the
correlation between Sigma n and the loss
I'm going to take the correlation
between Sigma I and the uh output of the
decoder of the earthquake which is still
a scalar
and then average over the N uh
and things that come out from the decode
yeah I mean I haven't put the proof here
but the proof is indicator so we can we
can talk about that
so that's the first step again this is
not a big step but nonetheless it makes
your life a little bit easier okay so
what do we do next so of course the next
step is to bound the bitwise okay so
we're going to do that next
now what we do is Max taught us in the
morning we will bound this complexity
first using Dudley and propane integral
okay
so we Define something called again it's
not my definition this is all out there
in the literature on bounds of radi
marker complexity so what is covering
number covering numbers in the minimum
minimum number of again balls should be
in code here to cover a given space in
this case we are not covering space but
we are covering a class of functions so
f t is a class of functions so what is
covering number informally it's the
size of the minimum set of functions you
need
so that
uh basically at least one of them is
going to be a good approximation of F at
any input Lambda okay so this should
hold for any Lambda
right and then I'm asking that how many
what's the minimum class of functions
that can sort of approximate it
within a given budget of Epsilon
okay all right
and then there is a result which says
that you know with this
um covering number defined we can
actually bound the radi marker
complexity the the bitwise radio marker
complexity in terms of uh
complicated looking object but
nonetheless it looks as a function of
the log of the covering number right
okay so what next
again I have done there's no innovation
from our side at this point uh what are
we going to do next we're going to now
bound the covering number of the
function plus which is derived from the
decoder architecture right
okay so let's bond the covering number
now we use another property that if the
function class can be written as a
composition of functions
and it turns out for us it is because
our function class is uh unrolling of
the Tanner graph and there is you know
one layer after another after another
and
for our specific form if the weight
matrices let's say U V and W which are
the learnable objects uh if they are if
that's a satisfy a Lipschitz property
then the covering number
for the function plus F can be written
as a product of the covering numbers of
the individual matrices themselves
okay this is a standard known result
what we show is that for neural VP
decoders we can show the slip ships
property okay so
namely there exists some rows rho W1 row
W2 and so on basically these rows
corresponds to some
some constants which may depend on W's
themselves uh so that
F minus F Dash is less than a linear
combination of the
the two Norm of the W minus W primes
okay that's essentially the lip ships
property
now with this
and the first fact we can then bound the
covering number uh for the bitwise
function plus fdj as the product of the
covering numbers of these individual
guys
okay so that's yes can you remind us
what are W3 and W4 oh there are so this
is just a generic statement of uvw there
are four
types of weight matrices that are
learned
um there is a initial W in the beginning
a Big W at the end which combines the
final thing for a decision and then for
every layer there is a check node update
variable node update so for every guy
there is W1 W2 for the first check
variable update then W1 W for the next
one and so on
okay so if there are t iterations in BP
there are
two matrices per layer and then one at
the beginning one at the end so two
times t plus two is the total number of
trainable matrices
all right so using lipstickness of the
NPP decoder we can then bound this as a
product of these objects
and then okay so what next what should
we do next
we should think about bounding these
guys right that's what we're going to do
now this is where we're going to exploit
the specific structure of the Ws where
are the W's coming from W's are derived
from the structure of the parity check
Matrix the Tanner graph tanagraph is
nice it sparse we know the precise
structure
it has DV non-zero entries in every
column and so on so forth
and so that's where we will extract the
sparsity of the W to get upper bound on
the covering number for those individual
products okay
so here's another result again known
from the literature which we use that
let W be the space of all R by C
matrices
uh so that their l0 non is q
uh and this bound of spectral Norm uh
being BW then we can bound the covering
number in terms of uh this quantity okay
okay I'm not going to prove this result
this is again a standard result
now with this in mind
when we plug this thing
sorry we take this result and then we
plug it back in our previous expression
combine everything together
and then we arrive at our main result
so this is our main result which says
that the generalization gap for neural
belief propagation decoder is bounded by
this expression which I'm going to tell
you about in a second plus other things
which are standard stuff so 4 by m this
is a standard pack bound or you know
generalization bound that you get term
in the generalization boundary Gates
Again 1 by square root 2m this is again
a standard term what's the new term it's
this term
so let's see what does this look like
it has of course a dependence on m m is
remember the training data set size so
we expect as M grows the Gap should
reduce which is good
now it also shows something interesting
that n shows up button doesn't show up
exponentially so it's this Gap does not
blow up with larger block lens it does
blow up with larger block lines but
mildly all right so it blows up at
square root n okay so square root n
times another logic
um of course it also blows up with t t
is the number of training decoding
iterations decoding iterations for me is
the number of layers in the decoder okay
so as the number of layers in the
network grow it also grows but it grows
roughly like order of t
okay it also grows with DV
if DV DV is the variable node degree
which means if DV is higher my parity
check Matrix is more dense
so it's harder to learn more dense code
decoders for more dense matrices rather
than sparse matrices
all right any questions about the main
result
so where is DC oh so I mean DB DC are
related to n and K so you know
where is K
does not show up here
I think we may have Loosely upper
bounded it by by one or something yeah
but yes that's a good point actually we
have a I mean a pro already in the paper
where we put all the four things
together and sort of study the interplay
between
but yeah good point
all right so I mean here are just some
you know cartoonish plots we just took
this expression plotted it and see what
it looked like uh of course as these are
not real experiments these are just
taking the right hand side of this
expression and plotting them so we see
of course you know we go down as M
increases linear increase in the Gap as
the number of uh has this width of the
network increases
uh square root n increase as the
codeword length increases for us I felt
this was the most interesting result
the reason why this was interesting is
when we started working on this problem
we started using BC Dimension and
precursor to radimarker complexity
methods those all those methods gave us
exponential dependence on n
so it was not clear to us when we
started looking at this problem can we
get a better dependence on the Block
length and so this is what we get at
least as of now from this method
and also linear dependence on DV now of
course I'm not claiming this is the best
there is of course room for improvement
and I am not aware of any other paper
which has done this analysis for neural
decoders at this point
um so I'm gonna I don't know how much
time do I have
three minutes okay perfect
um so the other approach as I mentioned
you know one could use VC Dimension and
again I think there is packed based
methods one could use for this problem
yes question
even more interested to me is
the nms are growing at the same rate is
there are some the reason for that that
the number of samples once it's more
than number of examples once it's more
than that
you start seeing like
not really I mean you still have uh one
by square root 10 term here right but
that will be small right one side and
them are comparable
and both are large the customer will
dominate but let's say m is a large
construction of fact
so something nice is happening around n
equal to n at least in this bound right
correct
deeper
explanation beyond that
yeah good observation
um all right so as I said you know there
are other possible approaches we can try
at least we try two approaches but we
did not get at least uh satisfactory
dependence on the Block length using
these methods and you know there's this
approach Paris method is promising but
it's very hard to
complete closed form expression and nice
Expressions uh which which shows sort of
clear dependence on the decoder
strategic Matrix and its parameters so
this is a valid approach but I don't
know how to compute or bound it you know
as of now
um
so I'm going to show you maybe two other
generalizations so we can generalize
this easily for a regular parity check
matrices so instead of regular if things
are irregular we can do that no problem
um as I promised in the beginning if the
channel likelihood ratios are unbounded
uh then we can play a small trick and
also deal with this the way to do this
is you know sort of uh do a conditioning
on the event that likelihood ratio is
unbounded and then sort of sandwich that
by a you know tailbond of caution and
the remaining for the bounded case you
can then get the same bound and then
optimize over the the threshold that you
pick
okay so these type of tricks you can
play
all right I think that's pretty much
what I have to say and then since this
is a trustworthy machine learning
session you may trust your artificial
decoder
and this paper we posted an archive on
Friday
and luckily the next paper below our
paper was Max's paper a unified
framework for information theoretic
generalization bounds
so we can learn from this and maybe
applied
all right and that's what I'll finish
[Applause]
[Music]
intuition on why this group technique is
better than fat base or DC Dimension
like why those
so I think the uh Dudley integral is I
think one of the main uh ingredients
right I mean it gives a lot of Thick
Growth uh in in that covering number uh
as opposed to I mean there are several
ways to count the same thing but I think
the link to ziggles is much more tighter
that's my understanding is that okay uh
yeah yeah sure
understand
okay
so foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
so they don't show all possible
codewords in the space but they show a
small subset of code words into space
and then you know customizing
realizations
um
okay thank you
my pleasure
the last talk today
um
also from Arizona